tenemos aquí los derivados del ácido
acético que vimos en el vídeo pasado que
como tienen aquí un enlace doble o dos
podrían estar estabilizados por
resonancia y justo lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo es ver qué tanto estos
derivados están estabilizados por la
resonancia ok pero para eso vamos a
necesitar más espacio
así es que vamos a volver a escribir por
aquí los derivados del ácido acético el
primer derivado que vimos fue la acepta
mida que es un grupo carbón hilo con una
cadena de carbonos y después en lugar
del grupo h del ácido carboxílicos
tenemos aquí un nitrógeno que tiene dos
hidrógenos ok esta es la acet amiga
acepta
me da el segundo derivado que vimos es
el acetato de metilo que es un grupo
carbón hilo con una cadena de carbonos
de un lado y del otro lado un oxígeno
que está unido con otra cadena de
carbonos que en este caso es un metilo
ok entonces esta parte nos dice que es
un acetato
hace
tacto y esta parte nos dice que es un
acetato de metilo
de
tilo pero vamos a necesitar más espacio
entonces lo vamos a poner por aquí y
después vimos un anhídrido acético que
es como dos ácidos asépticos pegados o
sea un grupo carbón hilo con un grupo
metilo y por aquí un oxígeno que se une
al otro grupo carbón y lo que tiene otro
grupo metilo y es un anhídrido acético
y
brito
kiko y al final vimos un cloruro de acet
y lo que es un grupo carbón hilo con un
grupo metilo por un lado y por el otro
en lugar del grupo h de los ácidos
carboxílicos tenemos un cloro y este es
cloruro de acetil o
cloruro de acet y lo hace tilo y todos
estos son derivados del ácido acético
que vimos en el vídeo pasado
este es el ácido acético que es un ácido
carboxílicos del cual a través de
ciertas reacciones de las cuales ya
vimos uno ya sabemos cómo obtener el
cloruro de acetil oa partir del ácido
acético y tal vez veamos en los próximos
vídeos cómo obtener estos pero bueno
tenemos aquí estos cuatro derivados del
ácido acético y lo que queremos saber es
qué tan estables son estas moléculas y
para hacer eso lo que tenemos que hacer
es pensar en cuáles otras estructuras de
resonancia tienen cada una de estas
moléculas así es que vamos a empezar a
analizar qué tanta resonancia tiene la
acet amiga que tenemos aquí un nitrógeno
que hace tres enlaces está haciendo uno
con este carbono y otros dos con estos
dos hidrógenos y tiene otro par de
electrones libres ahora en esta molécula
este nitrógeno es rico en electrones
porque es considerablemente más electro
negativo que los hidrógenos y también es
más electro negativo que el carbono
entonces una cosa que podría pasar
fácilmente es que este nitrógeno le
regale uno de sus electrones al carbono
y entonces el carbono suelte uno de los
electrones del doble enlace
y regresé a este oxígeno de aquí ok
entonces
lo que nos quedaría serían estos dos
carbonos este carbono del grupo carbón y
lo ahora tiene un enlace simple con este
oxígeno pero ahora tiene un enlace doble
con este nitrógeno
hidrógeno que está enlazado con dos
hidrógenos claro que ahora este oxígeno
se quedó con este electrón y por lo
tanto ahora tiene una carga negativa y
este nitrógeno le dio uno de sus
electrones al carbono y entonces tiene
una carga positiva entonces esta es una
estructura de resonancia o estructura de
contribución de la hace temida y es
bastante estable aunque hoy vamos a
escribirlo por aquí
bastante estable
table ahora vamos a analizar el acetato
de metilo que es un esther tenemos por
aquí este oxígeno que es más electro
negativo que los dos carbonos con los
que está enlazado y tiene dos pares de
electrones libres y el oxígeno es
bastante electro negativo entonces
podría hacer esto mismo que hizo el
nitrógeno enlace está mina entonces
podría llegar a darle uno de sus
electrones a este carbono de aquí y
formar un doble enlace y entonces este
carbono tendría que tomar uno de estos
dos electrones y regresárselo a este
oxígeno y entonces nuestra estructura de
resonancia se vería así tenemos este
oxígeno con un grupo metilo
y ahora tiene un doble enlace con este
carbono doble enlace con el carbono del
carbón y lo que ahora en lugar de tener
un doble enlace con este otro oxígeno
ahora tiene un enlace simple ok y tiene
otro grupo metilo este enlace es el que
se acaba de formar y como este oxígeno
le dio este electrón a este carbono
entonces ahora tiene una carga positiva
y este oxígeno se quedó con este
electrón entonces ahora tiene una carga
negativa así es que esta es una
estructura de resonancia del acetato de
metilo pero la pregunta interesante aquí
es cuál de estos dos es más estable y la
respuesta la podemos encontrar en la
tabla periódica ok la aceta mira hace un
doble enlace con un nitrógeno mientras
que el acetato de metilo tiene un
oxígeno lo crea y tenemos aquí al
nitrógeno y al oxígeno y el oxígeno está
derecha del nitrógeno lo cual significa
que el oxígeno es más electro negativo
que el nitrógeno o sea le gusta mucho
más abrazar a sus electrones entonces ya
podemos regresar aquí tenemos un
nitrógeno y aquí tenemos un oxígeno y el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
nitrógeno entonces es menos probable que
el oxígeno vaya a acceder uno de sus
electrones y eso significa que nos vamos
a encontrar con esta estructura de
resonancia con menos frecuencia si la
aceta me da es bastante estable entonces
el acetato de metilo es simplemente
estable
table bay simplemente estable
simple
mente
y ahora vamos con el anhídrido
este oxígeno tiene dos pares de
electrones libres el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que los dos carbonos
con los que está enlazado y al igual que
en el este podría darle uno de sus
electrones a este carbono y entonces
este carbono le daría este electrón a
este oxígeno y entonces tenemos este
oxígeno
enlazado con este grupo carbón y lo que
tiene un grupo metilo y de este lado
pues este oxígeno ya le dio un electrón
a este carbono y entonces tiene un
enlace doble con ese carbono que ahora
tiene únicamente un enlace simple con
este oxígeno
y su grupo metilo y claro este oxígeno
perdió uno de sus electrones por lo que
ahora tiene una carga positiva mientras
que este oxígeno recibió este electrón
entonces ahora tiene una carga negativa
ahora eso no es lo único que podría
pasar también podría pasar que en lugar
de que este oxígeno le mandara uno de
sus electrones a este carbono se lo
mandará a este otro carbono de aquí a
este otro carbono de aquí y entonces lo
que tendríamos es una estructura de
resonancia que se ve así esta parte se
queda intacta olviden las flechas
amarillas aunque aquí se me olvidó decir
que como este carbono acaba de recibir
un electrón de este oxígeno tiene que
soltar uno de estos dos electrones y
pasárselo al oxígeno ok entonces tenemos
otra estructura de resonancia que se ve
así esta parte se queda intacta tenemos
aquí un grupo carbón y lo con el grupo
metilo con su enlace al oxígeno y este
oxígeno ahora tiene un enlace doble con
este carbono enlace doble y este carbono
estoy carbono que antes pertenecía a
este grupo carbón hilo
ahora tiene un solo enlace simple con el
oxígeno un enlace con el oxígeno y un
grupo metilo el grupo metilo y por
supuesto este oxígeno le paso un
electrón a este carbono entonces ahora
tiene una carga positiva y este oxígeno
tiene este electrón demás entonces tiene
una carga negativa ok entonces tenemos
estas dos estructuras de resonancia y
bueno tal vez pienses que como hay dos
estructuras de resonancia entonces este
anhídrido está más estabilizado por la
resonancia pero eso no necesariamente es
cierto en otras moléculas tal vez puede
ser cierto pero en los anhídridos no al
contrario porque estas dos estructuras
no suceden al mismo tiempo esta
estructura de resonancia estabiliza esta
parte de la molécula mientras que esta
otra parte de la molécula en esta
estructura este doble enlace sigue
siendo muy reactivo mientras que en esta
otra estructura deja a este otro doble
enlace sin estabilizar y entonces puede
llegar otra molécula y robarse uno de
los electrones del doble enlace más
fácilmente ok aunque recuerda que en las
estructuras de resonancia no es como que
la molécula pase de este estado a este
estado y luego regrese más bien los
electrones van saltando en todos estos
átomos y entonces el anhídrido acético
es menos estable que el éster ok
porque piénsalo los mismos electrones de
este oxígeno están únicamente saltando
entre estos átomos mientras que en el
anhídrido los electrones de este oxígeno
tienen que saltar para este lado y para
este otro dividen su tiempo entre estos
dos carbonos así es que cada uno de
estos enlaces dobles está estabilizado
la mitad del tiempo de lo que lo está
este otro enlace doble así es que este
anhídrido está menos estable
menos estable
table y finalmente llegamos al cloruro
de acetil o ahora resulta que el cloruro
es tan pero tan electro negativo que es
muy improbable casi nunca sucede que el
cloro le regale uno de sus electrones a
este carbono porque para que eso llegara
a suceder este cloro necesitaría tener
una carga negativa sin embargo en esta
molécula no tiene ninguna carga negativa
así es que en realidad el cloruro de
acetil no tiene ninguna estructura de
resonancia y por lo tanto es el menos
estable de los cuatro es el menos
menos estable
table de los 4 de los 4 derivados del
ácido acético en fin aquí ya tenemos
toda la escala de qué tan estables son
cada uno de los derivados del ácido
acético la aceta me da es el derivado
más estable y va disminuyendo conforme
nos vamos a la derecha ahora porque nos
estamos preguntando qué tan estables son
los derivados del ácido acético pues qué
tan estables son nos dice que tan
probable es que en una reacción con los
elementos adecuados terminemos con una u
otra molécula voy a dibujar aquí el
ácido carboxílicos
ok en la esterificación de fisher vimos
como podíamos obtener acetato de metilo
a partir de un ácido carboxílicos y en
el siguiente vídeo vimos cómo podíamos
obtener cloruro de acetil o a partir de
un ácido acético y en general hay
reacciones en todos los sentidos pero
entre más estable es una molécula es más
probable que la obtengamos en cierta
reacción lo que hay por ejemplo es mucho
más fácil obtener una acepta mida a
partir de un cloruro de acet y lo que al
revés y es más fácil obtener un acetato
de metilo a partir de un anhídrido
acético que al revés e incluso es más
fácil obtener una acepta mi da a partir
de un ácido carboxílicos porque la z1000
tiene una resonancia que es incluso
mejor que la resonancia del ácido
carboxílicos de la que proviene entonces
tiene una solución tenemos muchas a
minas flotando y de estas moléculas es
bastante probable que terminemos con
acepta amiga y más adelante vamos a ver
acciones en las que pasamos de unas de
estas moléculas a otras que siempre es
más fácil pasar de una molécula de la
derecha a una molécula de la izquierda y
próximamente vamos a estudiar algunos de
esos mecanismos de reacción